we're going live
[Music]
okay we should be live uh i'll wait to
see if there's any anything in chat
to let us know
[Music]
and we are live
thanks akash hey guys
so i have here with me rev and rev if
you'll introduce yourself for us
hello everyone my name is rev labridian
i am the vice president of simulation
technology and omniverse here at um
nvidia really really thrilled to be here
with uh with harrison to
to walk through all of the cool stuff
we're announcing at gtc
yeah cool um so if you want to tell us
like about some of the
kind of new things that we're expecting
to see about omniverse and all that
wow yeah there's there's a whole lot of
stuff um that's going to be revealed
here in the keynote
for those of you that haven't seen it
already essentially the whole keynote
was created with with omniverse and on
pretty much every demo
uh that we show for anything else has
been has an omnivorous component to it
omniverse is our
uh
our virtual world creation and
simulation platform
and
first and foremost we built it for
ourselves
so that so that we could do our work in
all of the areas that are
important to us at nvidia from
uh robotics to computer vision
to
uh autonomous vehicles
um to
to virtual production uh
of of the keynote itself
uh so
uh the big announcements for omniverse
directly are um there were four of them
uh
that were specifically about omniverse
first is uh there's a new app that we're
going to be releasing soon called
omniverse showroom
uh it's a easy to use app where you can
get a whole bunch of little cool demos
to kind of see the power of omniverse
and all of nvidia's technologies
um
we're going to start off with a
few demo lits inside it but over time
there's going to be a huge number of
them
that we'll just keep adding every time
we do something cool new physics
technology and uai technology will
uh we'll be adding adding one to
showroom
uh
the
the next one is omniverse farm
this is a a system that we built um that
is uh very
very powerful it's in general it allows
you to take
virtually any
any batch kind of process including
um including rendering within omniverse
to do synthetic data generation or
render frames for your for your videos
but also just about anything else like
you could do file format conversion or
uh
physics simulation whatever you want to
run on a on a
in batch on one machine or more
you can easily set up omniverse farm to
to manage
all of your resources and distribute
that work
we used it
to create this keynote and actually the
previous one as well
we
we had at some points 1200 gpus all
running simultaneously
across our workstations
uh to our to various clusters we have
around nvidia and different data centers
to to the cloud
uh we we use the public cloud as well so
all of the stuff you see rendered in
there
um
is that what something like anything for
like uh
the car manufacturing like we seem to
see that a lot is that something similar
is that what you're using for that
uh yeah for the for the beautiful videos
that that you see rendered for like be
it the bmw factory of the future yeah um
there's there's a multiple rendering
modes in in omniverse
we have the real time mode
but we also have an offline rendering
mode
path tracing as well as the ira renderer
which is an extremely
physically accurate uh
really true simulation of the physics of
light and so you have a spectrum of
quality and accuracy
um
versus versus speed right for for the
keynote
we want everything to be as beautiful as
possible so we can flip a switch and go
take all the stuff from that's real time
and give it give the computers a little
bit more time to to render the images in
a more beautiful accurate way
and um
uh
something more similar to what
um
what uh what's done in film you know for
visual effects and and cg movies where
they they often can spend many many
hours or even days worth of computer
time to render a single image you have
the option to do that
um and and the with omniverse farm
we now give the capability of doing this
kind of large-scale rendering to anyone
by allowing you to harness all the
resources available to you whether
that's
you know your workstation maybe your
notebook
to
to
instances in the cloud that you're
renting
you can combine them all together and
make it one big resource pool and
distribute that work
to it easily and it's nicely integrated
with
with our omniverse apps so with just the
click of a button you can submit
thousands of
frames to get rendered wherever you have
resources it's really really really
powerful stuff and i think it's the
beginning of
uh
of of this journey that we're going to
take everybody along to unlock
the capabilities of all the computing
resources that that are that are
available these days through through the
cloud and and
um even just in front of you that we're
not harnessing to its fullest because
it's just so hard to
to manage
said setting up all of that work um
the the other
two things that we're announcing um
uh we
first is uh ar
so we're we're making available um the
apps necessary to connect
uh to an omniverse server so
uh
so the rendering can happen on the
omniverse server side but displayed
remotely on on a tablet or or your phone
when you say like omniverse server do
you mean like like someone can have that
running locally as well not just yes
yeah absolutely yes
uh yeah this is not cloud versus not it
could be either but you could you could
run a
uh on your laptop or your workstation
that's rtx capable
um
run run create or an omniverse kit based
app
and stream
um stream that rendering over to your
ios device
uh using our omniverse remote app and
and uh
the the device knows its position
imposed in the world through
through slam and the tracking that that
it's doing to localize itself in the
world that's fed back to
um to the omniverse rendering server
um
which which then affects the virtual
camera so and in effect what it does is
it allows you to have an ar experience
where the rendering
quality and the content the scale the
content you can do
is is at the scale of the computer you
have available to you uh the workstation
or
whatever you have in the cloud instead
of the device that you're displaying it
on and to cut in for a second so we're
watching like the intro to the uh to the
keynote now this is this is all from
this is all rendered with like omniverse
correct
oh absolutely and this is actually
jensen's kitchen in his home
uh i've been there quite a few times and
it looks exactly like that uh it's it's
kind of freaky that's kind of cool that
looks
it is
i the first time i watched i'd like the
the last one though he was in his
kitchen
i could not have told you he was in the
kitchen
or he was in like a fake virtual kitchen
yeah
yeah we're um
uh
we're at the point now where
where we can we have a gem keynote
reproduce
reality pretty faithfully
um now kudos to our our creative team
which is world class
uh the the artists we have on our
creative team
uh are
are some of the best in the world that
come from visual effects and cg world
and and so
so they they built his kitchen
uh and and applied all of those
materials and matched it uh exactly
you know doing using
using their their craft
our goal at um nvidia and particularly
with omniverse is to democratize that
ability we want we want to
over time make it easier for for the
layman who's not an expert to be able to
construct scenes like that at that
quality fidelity and reproduce the real
world faithfully like that
and with with the
um
uh
advent of ai and deep learning
um we believe that there's a path there
and it's not that far off
we're going to be able to
take average people and give them tools
that are ai
amplified by ai
to turn them into expert artists
and craftsmen 3d craftsmen
i just saw a question in the chat uh how
long did it take i was wondering the
same thing so like that kitchen looked
so good so like how long did it take
to to design that and then also how long
did it take to actually like render that
video because surely that's like what
you were talking about like the highest
end possible
you know i don't i don't have the exact
numbers in front of me
but um
i
i believe that they they worked on
modeling and
texturing the scene over the course of
many months
but also not in the front burner um that
we
we decided we were going to do that
a year ago at gtc fall last year
um we had done an actual kitchen keynote
where it was in his kitchen and they
used that opportunity to go take
thousands of pictures of the of the
kitchen um so that we could rebuild it
with photogrammetry
um but
but we knew that the quality of what
you're gonna get from photogrammetry
would not be what's
um what we needed uh that was just done
for reference
so from there we spent months
i'm still trying to get a grip on
reality then so so the so the first gtc
that i saw with him in his kitchen was
when he like pulled out the a100s from
the oven right is that that was fake
that was gtc spring of 2020. it was like
march or april or whatever that was
right when coveted started
so was that real or fake
uh that was real oh okay
but there were scenes from there that
like
like kind of like he did here where it
kind of explodes into a like a
clearly a cgi type scene so was it i
don't think there wasn't that one uh we
did that later
yeah you guys are messing with my brain
i guess
yeah that that that keynote i mean we
weren't planning for that that year we
had we had plans for some other amazing
stuff we wanted to do and we're going to
do it live like we always used to do
before yeah and there's all this cool
stuff that i we were going to show off
in omniverse on the live stage
uh with
with with some magic interaction with um
with the scene but we had to scrap all
of that because everybody had to go home
for quarantine
so we just cooked up the the kitchen
keynote idea
out of necessity there
but as we were doing that we realized
hey why don't we turn
the kitchen turned out to be a pretty
iconic thing
kind of like his leather jacket
everybody was enthralled with it and and
his spatulas and all that
so we had the
the idea to
um to reconstruct in the virtual world
and now we have that kitchen preserved
forever so even even when he remodels
his house
uh we we can keep that um and use it for
for our purposes forever forevermore
oh i muted him i'm sorry i thought i'd
pause it there we go
so like the background here
is that real or fake it is not unusual
for us i believe that's rendered yeah
i'm not sure
sometimes they do sometimes it's real
sometimes it's not this this was done um
using these modern virtual production
techniques where where we have a
led wall system
um and uh and a robotic arm
that driving the camera right right
but is that it's kind of like how the
mandalorian
was done
so is he
yeah so like when you guys do those
scenes is is jensen just on a green
screen or or what no no he's not on a
green screen that that's behind him and
the on the led walls
projected so it's in camera
compositing like the mandalorian yeah
maybe i might not
uh maybe i shouldn't be giving it away i
think our creative team probably wants
to talk about some of the magic later
but but yeah we we we do all kinds of
stuff so our team is super pro
and um
and they're they're pushing everything
to the limits
uh we love
um using them as our guinea pigs for
omniverse because
um
you know as we develop uh all these
cutting-edge technologies and push the
limits of real-time rendering in physics
um
somebody has to use it the first time
and tell us what what works well and
what doesn't work well and what's buggy
and all that and so we
uh we force it on our own teams first
and they they kind of find the limits of
it go through all the pain curse at us
and then uh we make it better so that by
the time we give it to others it um it's
already proven
well definitely like one thing i really
enjoyed like at least on the outside
looking into omniverse like i'd heard
the name and how old is omniverse like
or or really when was the first time you
guys mentioned omniverse
the first time we mentioned it publicly
was gtc spring 2019 that was the first
demo we put up there where we showed
a collaborative demo along with our
nascent renderer
and kit
we we showed three applications
connecting simultaneously it was unreal
engine 4
um
substance painter and maya
and and you had three different people
live
uh editing the world simultaneously
something we we hadn't seen before and
they were yeah they were doing this
magic there but the
but the vision for omniverse uh was much
greater than what we showed there and we
knew that but it's just too hard to
to to tell everything about the vision
all at once you kind of have to
uh do it in stages and actually show
that it works it wasn't all done yet
either it's still not done where this is
going to be a continuous thing that we
we contribute to
but we
we knew that um
we needed to build something like
omniverse a long long time ago let me
just pause pause for a sec so what's on
the screen right now i believe this is
all this is all omniverse is that right
yes it is and that's the real-time mode
i believe so that that's showing
it's a visualization of the route
planning
uh done by our new reopt system that's
using the uh accelerated
uh
route planning system to make uh
logistics and all that uh far more
efficient
um
so the the route plans are fed into into
the omniverse here to drive these robots
so we can visualize them
doing their work
yeah that's so cool i uh yeah one of the
things that i found really cool about
omniverse like when i first like started
using it so all i was really trying to
do is get a simulator for
for a robot that's it and so i was
looking at all these other simulators
but with omniverse like
one of the things that's so easy is
like you you have like that urdf file
that describes the robot
but then when you save that like when i
spend all this time like creating the
scene i'm doing that all like manually
it's all a bunch of like drag and drop
kind of stuff and like you just bring in
like a ground plane or some other asset
and stuff like that and then you just
save that as that like usd file and
it at least like i'm sure that kind of
concept with like maybe with like
blender or something like that is super
common but i don't know anything about
blender and at least in omniverse like
when i'm trying to create a
like a scene for my robot to
navigate in or whatever it's just so
simple as opposed to with any of these
other robot simulators you have to like
code it and it's it's like coding
like a ui it's it's so painful to like
code something that is visual like that
at least for me and i think it's true
for a lot of people whereas
here like if i want to have two or three
robots like i just copy and paste the
robot like it's really simple and i drag
it exactly where i want it to be
and if i want like a ramp i just
add in a ramp visually and then i can
save that and then the same thing is
like other people can do that and they
can just share that with me like they
can share their usd file with me and
then if i want to make some little tweak
or edit or whatever like it's really
easy i mean it's way easier than any
other robot sim out there and obviously
that's not the only you know it's not
just for simulating robots there's it's
more than that but it's like it's even
just for that it's it's
it's got to be the best if not one of
the best simulators and i feel like
people don't
like that's not the first name that
comes to people's mind when they think
of robot sims so that's why like i'm
super excited about omniverse and just
isaac sim inside of omniverse for that
reason like it's just so
it's so easy and then on top of that
yeah it's it's definitely the best
looking sim too especially with like i'm
so glad to hear you say that uh and and
our isaac sim team and the omniverse
team
will um will really appreciate hearing
that because they've they've been
working on this for a long time and and
what you said
right there about what um
the benefits of using it with making it
easy to construct these worlds to bring
in this
this data together and combine the
robotic stuff with with other 3d data
that's precisely why we built it because
we we had those same problems internally
um there's a lot of really great tools
out there for for constructing 3d worlds
tools like blender and the autodesk
tools like maya and max and houdini and
whatnot but
the number of people on this earth who
really are masters at using the 3d
software
it's pretty small
um it's it's essentially
you know people that do visual effects
and that sort of stuff or make games
um and you know there's a large number
of people that are doing that but not in
the grand scheme of things
if you're doing anything else
if you're doing robotics you're doing
uh simulations your factories
you probably don't have one of those
experts or any number of those experts
like a team of them on your team
to to go build virtual worlds for you
um and and we saw this internally at
nvidia because we have some of those
experts but we also have a whole bunch
of engineers uh who who need to do
simulations of 3d worlds for
for building robots autonomous vehicles
uh and and various other things that we
do
uh so so first and foremost we said how
do we make this
how do we make it possible
so that we can leverage all of the
existing tools all of the content that's
out there
to to assemble together 3d worlds that
could then be used for simulation
and and um
and this is what we designed uh we said
first we need to create omniverse and
and make this connection and have these
standards
to to make it easy to bring data in and
out of all the uh other tools have a
common language just like we do for the
web we have we take html and
and all of the web standards for granted
but they're the key
to why to why we
we can do any of the stuff we're doing
right now
we need the equivalent of that for 3d
world so we started from there
but that's only the beginning of the
journey once you have that foundation
you could then
you can then link in
uh
virtually any any 3d tool that's out
there any 3d simulator
and and you get this awesome network
effect every new thing that's added into
the system
everybody benefits from it so you
benefit from the fact that some tool
that you will never use directly is
connected because somebody else out
there can now
feed you data and information
that you could leverage
yeah do you guys have any plan to or
maybe i've there is something i've just
missed it but like one of the things
like when i got isaac sim was there was
just like one big asset package that you
could grab so there was like a warehouse
in there and stuff like that is there
any plan or is there something i've
missed where you can get uh
like
like people can share
you know like for example that's there's
like cities and stuff that people are
building and it's like wow i really want
that
i want to just download and use that
is there a way for people to share those
so yeah first first off like we we want
to make more of those things so our plan
is to increase the number of assets that
just come with omniverse and any you can
see over the course of the past year
we've been steadily increasing that and
i think that's going to accelerate even
faster so out of the box you're going to
get a bunch but you can never have
enough either uh one of the
great things about omniverse is
is uh all the connectors we have to all
the different 3d tools and other other
systems which makes it really really
easy
for you to import um
uh content that exists in other
libraries
uh so
so there's there there are uh
a bunch of 3d content libraries
out there you can just go buy
or some of them provide free assets as
well like uh shutter stocks turbo squid
uh there's they've been around
turbosquid's been around now for a few
decades so there's there's a large
library of 3d content that's been built
up over the years million
or so so 3d models there you can go to
sketchfab
which is a newer one epic acquired them
recently
they have they have a bunch of create
content and all of it is available as
usd
uh so you could just download what was
either their free what was the name of
the shutterstock one um
turbo squid
turbo squid interesting
and is that just like a cg is that like
a single asset or would there be like
environment no it's a whole library it's
um
where artists artists build up scenes
and um they
they they sell them on that on the
marketplace so there's this marketplace
of uh there's many marketplaces of these
assets that that other artists can sell
on so
the problem has always been that
there there hasn't been a common
language a common format to describe
these assets
so as a roboticist you want you are dfs
but the artist might be using blender or
or maya
uh to create their assets and what they
upload as
um it probably isn't compatible exactly
with what you need so there's usually a
whole bunch of work you have to do to
ingest those assets convert them and
then you lose information like materials
and stuff typically in that process but
but with the standardization on usd
happening
that's becoming quickly it's becoming a
non-issue and that's what we're trying
to help with so given all the connectors
that we have you can take advantage of
those there's also the the stores that
um
are available um of with the with the
game engines with uh unreal there's the
unreal marketplace
there's also the unity marketplace
um so you can you can go get an uh go
buy assets from the unreal marketplace
and use the unreal engine connector to
convert to usd and connect it to the
omniverse nucleus server and bring it
right into i6m
that way as well there's there's many
many paths our whole
uh
intention here is to make it so that
everything becomes usd this common
standard and will provide
uh
as many tools as necessary to bring from
different
different forms and different tools into
that common form once it's there you can
use it for anything it's very easy to
move around and increasingly
usd is becoming the standard for many of
these marketplaces as well so
so we'll um
we you won't even have to convert in
many cases and in the future i think
that's going to become a non-issue
well at least for like converting from
urdf to usda
i found that to be very simple
as long as you know there's obviously
yeah we did a lot of work there i mean
the all that conversion stuff it's not
rocket science
but it's
it's a lot of work yeah you have to like
look at every corner case
and and just just convert tons and tons
of different content and a lot of the
times the the content you get um
they actually violate the standard
there are things the standards maybe
aren't well defined or whatever so so
you have to deal with
um malformed content and all of that and
so we we have this amazing team um
uh within omniverse within the omniverse
group that that's just
so dedicated and passionate about making
that work well and making it work right
and they've spent they've been spending
years um
every time we see some asset that didn't
convert overwrite they go figure out why
and they
they um
add a little bit more code a new path to
our converters
and the end effect is it just works for
you
and when it doesn't just work you let us
know and we'll be on it and we'll make
it um we'll make sure it works
because that's that's key to making all
of this happen if if we can't
exchange information freely
uh uh without friction with each other
there's no way we're gonna build the
large virtual worlds we need to do the
simulations
uh that we need for for all the stuff
we're talking about
someone in chat had noted that maybe
that converter
is only working on windows i lost the
question i saw it is is there any like
it depends which one uh so
uh
i'm not sure which one it was because he
just had a converter that he's talking
about and i couldn't remember i could
remember which one specifically that was
the ue4 connector he says oh yeah
maybe um
i i'm not sure we lo different
connectors work on different uh
operations basically we we can't
we can't go build connectors for every
application on every platform we just
there there's just too many tools out
there to connect to and so we and we as
as big as nvidia's we still have limited
resources so we have to prioritize which
ones
um which ones we do first and that's
based on what the demand is so if
there's a large amount of demand for a
particular tool and platform then then
we'll pop that up but on the for the
unreal engine connector we we actually
provide source for it
along with the connector so you can you
can go build it
and if you really need it to run on on a
non-windows platform
uh you're you're welcome to
to do that yourself
uh if there's a lot of demand for that
on linux which i don't think we've
received much that yeah then then we'll
consider supporting that as well it just
adds more burden to our qa and
and uh ci cd and all of that stuff
yeah i would imagine windows would be
the first one you would want to support
anyways
um the other question i have is like
with isaac sim
that is unless i'm mistaken only linux
is there a plan or eta for getting that
on windows or maybe i'm mistaken already
but i think
it's the same thing
yes we
our our hope and our plans are that
every everything we develop is on every
operating system
and linux is very very important to us
because
that is the operating system of the
cloud and we imagine
over time most of
most of how
most of the cycles that are uh run in
the omniverse are actually in the cloud
so
most people are going to be experiencing
omniverse and and our software running
somewhere remotely anyway and so
linux is kind of
uh the default for that
but um
for the robotics community
what we found is that primarily they are
linux and and unix in general unix-based
some run on windows but
at least on the
on the professional side or in academia
um uh on the forefront of robotics that
that was a requirement internally we
have a lot of robotics we're doing we
have
amazing roboticists we have a
a world-class
research lab a robotics one in um
[Music]
in seattle
led by dieter fox uh from university of
washington he's super famous the
community he wrote the textbook on
robotics um and all of them demanded
demanded linux because uh that's what
they run their robots on yeah so that's
what we prioritize first but we do we do
hope that sometime soon we'll we'll be
able to put a windows version out there
omniverse itself
is agnostic to this it's uh we
we uh from the start designed it so that
it can be multi-platform and linux as a
first-class citizen which is not often
the case for real-time rendering
um
uh engines typically
uh bias towards windows or consoles not
not linux because
uh because i was pretty surprised that
it was on linux to be honest so but but
we knew that we need to have linux for
the professionals that are in the spaces
that that we care about like robotics
and also because we need to run in the
cloud and so that's a lot of extra work
we did to get it to run there with
vulkan not not only are we running on
linux but we're we're pushing the limits
and the bleeding edge of ray tracing
with our drivers and and our hardware in
linux and that nobody else is pushing
our stuff like we are in in this case
yeah i want to pause for a second and go
back to uh
i assume this was omniverse as well the
uh
the avatar the jensen avatar
um
so i i've i've only seen it i haven't
actually used it so obviously this is
using his uh his voice as well which is
previously referred to as jarvis now
called riva i'm assuming and then also
the the avatar that's right is that
audio to face or what are you using for
that
yeah so this
uh this is a short piece in in the
or
i think it was like 30 seconds or a
minute it showed it here
but this is really i think
out of the whole keynote this is going
to end up being the
the thing that really stands out and
this is uh just a little bit of special
moment in history with what we created
here background for me is like yeah i
this has been like a dream of mine is to
to basically have and a little bit later
there's a more realistic so you got like
the avatar which is fun but then there's
also
another
i think it's audio to face but it's a
more realistic face
and
my goal would be to have yet a texas
speech of my voice and i've been like
slowly over time just like reading
audiobooks into my microphone and
captioning those and i've actually been
captioning those with uh well back then
jarvis now reva so i've been using that
to create the captions and then train
the texas speech model with my voice and
then you've got your voice you've got
the audio audio to face and then it's
like yeah you've got this whole thing
and then now it's like i don't even have
to it's like for it's like you said you
know jensen's kitchen is is forever
uh saved it it's it's the same thing for
for me is
i could just be forever
just live on forever making making
videos on youtube and maybe use a gpd3
or something to to continue making the
videos that's exactly right yeah yeah
um
if you had told me
10 years ago
that we were gonna
that ten years from that day we're gonna
have what we showed here with toy jensen
yeah uh uh i would have said you're
crazy that's never gonna happen in my
lifetime and
i've been continually
having to reevaluate
what's possible
since since this whole deep learning
thing started uh
my
it's been crazy but um
what we have here is
a set of
many amazing
innovations and and uh uh
uh inventions
it's it's not it's not just one thing so
it's starting with
uh with riva riva has actually many
components to it it's all things related
to speech and language
um it has uh asr so you speak to it and
it understands you well regardless of
what your accent is and
and uh it's extremely robust and uh
world class that's the other
fast and robust surprising to me was
just it's it's like it's instant i mean
it's not i mean it's not instant but
it's like i you know and it has to be we
because we need the end to end latency
from when you speak
until
uh till it gives you the answer back to
be
to be like what you would expect in a
normal conversation which is like a
second or less it's definitely less i
mean it's it's so fast and that was just
on you know my my gpus here at home and
so
yeah that that was i think for me what's
been so impressive is is how quick these
models are able to just do inference
a performance matters
in in real-time interactive applications
um performance is very very important
and that's that's what nvidia is about
it's about accelerating computing it's
what we do
so we
we go uh um torture ourselves to shave
off
microseconds
uh off of off of latency uh that's
that's that's
uh our
our mission our our driving
uh
force is to is to do that so and in this
case it's extremely important but we go
from we take the asr we take your audio
we convert it into
um
into a form into a text form that is
then
uh fed into our natural land uh language
understanding models
um
we just trained this uh huge model i
think it's like 500 something billion
parameters uh the megatron model we made
an announcement a few weeks back
uh of this model that we had trained
it's four times bigger than gpt three
the op openai model it was trained on
essentially all information
we had accessible
uh
to us from the internet like wikipedia
and stuff like that um
and
and basically it learned
all of that knowledge so
it takes that and it formulates an
answer based on based on what it's
learned
we then convert it the answer uh into
audio with um
uh
uh the text-to-speech
generation we have that was trained on
on jensen's voice so it sounds like
jensen is answering for this for this ai
um and
that is then fed into audio to face
to generate the facial animation
and
based on the states of the answers and
stuff we also trigger other animations
all of that is driven inside of
omniverse
in real time that whole scene is
rendered
in real time and interactive
um
so
so we not only have a
voice for representing the ai but now
the ai is embodied
uh
we
we have uh toy jensen
who can communicate with us not just
through voice but hand gestures and
and uh expressions when when it's
thinking
it's doing the inference on on the
question you asked you'll notice kind of
looks away
and and so
uh we're
we're we're right at the beginnings of
of creating an embodiment for our ais
that can communicate with us
through all the channels that that we
take for granted as humans
uh we know now after being in lockdown
and quarantine for almost two years how
important it is to be in person with
others and and get get all of that
bandwidth of information much more than
just the voice
um communication and so we're we're
providing these ai's a mechanism to do
that in these virtual worlds
um
and eventually we'll
we'll extend that to our robots so we
can we can have them teleport out of the
virtual world into our real world
so with the uh with the
jensen toy
uh how much audio of jensen's voice was
used there and then did you use um was
it the transfer learning toolkit uh is
that what you guys used to do it or
i believe so within reva we have
we have some mechanisms i can't tell you
the exact numbers and stuff but there's
some way with very small amounts of
training we can we can do that quality
of
of
uh text-to-speech and it's getting
better and better all the time i know
for a fact that we it's not a lot of
data because
uh jensen's time is it's precious
so so we couldn't put him in a
in an audio recording booth for days at
a time yeah i think that's the last time
i looked at the uh speech to text i
forget you you know there's the default
voice and then they're actually i don't
think that the transfer learning toolkit
even had like the option
to do any sort of transfer learning on
that into a custom voice and as far as i
know kind of the
uh
there's really no good industry standard
way to to do transfer learning on a
voice that sounds pretty good yeah so
that's part of riva and and what you're
going to see
well
there's a bunch of announcements uh
coming out around here so you can dig
into the details as as they come out but
whatever we're announcing now isn't the
end we're we have a lot of other stuff
we're cooking up in-house
and all of that will be made available
as soon as it's ready
so riva with riva we're just at the
beginnings uh of this and we're moving
very fast
so you can expect all of the stuff that
you want it's not going to be long till
until you can get access to it um even
if it
even if it's not available immediately
today
yeah yeah i mean i i've said it a
million times that i i think it's like
it's just so crazy like even when i was
going through the jarvis now riva stuff
um
it it's just like and you were even
saying like how many systems are
involved in doing just the toy jensen
thing right there's there's so many
uh
just like neural networks there's like
three of them and then you have all this
like rendering stuff oh no there's many
more than three there's many more i i
gave a very simplified view of
what happened there right well that's
what i mean is like you've got something
that's coming in for the asr stuff
you've got something that's got to
generate the audio and then even for the
asr there's i don't even know how many
are involved just with asr because yeah
you've got
obviously something's got to process
that audio something has to like
transcribe that audio and then even if
like even in the video that i did with
it you can even see that sometimes as
you as you're speaking it has the the
the caption or the transcription and
then it changes as
as you continue talking and it kind of
figures out what what are you actually
saying now
and so yeah there's just so much going
on and yeah just thinking about how much
time it would take
for
somebody even somebody like me who's got
a decent understanding of like i i could
do all this myself
but it's it's just so fast to grab these
things and just well it's come to the
point actually where individuals like us
we
we couldn't train any of these networks
ourselves yeah we built um internally we
have a super computer called celine
if you look at the top 500
supercomputers in the world there's the
top 500 list it's number five it's the
largest
enterprise industrial supercomputer in
the world uh the ones that are bigger
than us are
are all national labs they're like owned
by the governments
we built this supercomputer
for our researchers for our engineers to
go create these models
uh that
that um
megatron 500 billion parameter model we
created that took months to train on the
super computer
super computer costs i don't know
hundreds of millions of dollars
uh no individual could could justify
buying one of those
and just one run on it is many many
millions of dollars even on the uh the
dgx station that a100 machine that i had
for a little bit i trained
a transformer model for i call it like
gpit's generative python transformer
that was a 125 million with an m
parameter model i mean this is just a
baby model
and it it it took a decent amount of
time to train on that size machine so
yeah when we're talking about these
models that are 500 billion with a b
it's like
it's just required to even train those
kinds of models and have them be like
like yeah like with like the asr models
and stuff it's not available to average
average people or average companies yeah
that's a
even if you have the money to do it the
expertise to
to
to build that super computer
and to operate it and to design the
algorithms to go do the training on that
and have it scale and optimize for it
that that's a that's a rare skill uh and
it's it's one that
you know we've been
we've been cultivating for the whole
time we've been here at nvidia this is
this is exactly what we do
they uh and also it's not like you train
it and you're done that's it
the software is done the moment it's
done it's already outdated there's new
information in the world and
and the ai has advanced so you got to
start training the next one so it's just
kind of this endless thing
yeah uh
so so individuals
and small companies um
really really can't do all of this and
and uh our mission
is to make it so that individuals and
small companies and startups and
everyone
uh can have access to all this
technology we'll do it for them
the other big companies can go build it
for themselves
but
um somebody somebody has to make it for
everybody else to use so if you want
this this amazing stuff
uh
we'll go do the hard work for you and
and we're happy for you to take it and
use it to build your own amazing
applications you can go focus on on your
your specific value add
what are what are the what's the special
special sauce you're bringing to the
table you know you don't have to worry
about
building the basics
yeah yeah i mean i totally agree i mean
the models that everyone hears about
these days including like things like
gpd3 and all that
you just could never train those models
yourself and then a lot of times these
models are
closed you know so you can't download
that model you can't do any research on
that model we don't really tend to know
like how those models even even work or
like what are their downsides we can't
even do research into that whereas like
most people could do could do research
possibly not into gbd3 i don't probably
most people couldn't even inference gbt3
or they could but it would take a really
long time but but yeah it's it's just
it's cool to see a company that puts all
these things up like i remember the
first time i found uh
let's see what is it uh
i'm blanking on the name the nvidia gpu
cloud ngc that's a where you go and just
you can just download these models and
like you have them in like docker and
then also just like the weight files and
stuff like that you can just download
them and use them and i just think
that's so cool because like you said i
think a lot of these models people don't
respect that
it's not like you sat down and you just
knew like the exact hyper parameters for
that model and trained it one time
no yeah you you had to you had to make
many attempts go to many many iterations
and it's very expensive to do that i
mean probably first of all the machines
are in the millions but then also just
the amount of time money energy
you know human energy and also just
electricity that goes into making those
models i mean these are very very like
expensive to train models so it's just
it is really cool like we all want like
open models and stuff like that but you
know in the case of things like gpt3 and
stuff or even like megatron as you
mentioned um
i think people don't realize like how
how tough those are to make both in like
human capital and then just real like
money capital like it's just tough
right i think you're right i think
people don't really understand and
respect what's involved with that
um
one way to look at it is that modern ai
deep learning is essentially a
completely new form of software
development
in the past software development
was you could have you could have a
software engineer with a laptop uh and a
text editor
write a bunch do a bunch of typing and
then they run a compiler and it executes
for some period of time we complain it's
always too long but
uh but but really it's a short period of
time minutes uh minutes maybe
uh tens of minutes at most
and then you produce an executable that
you could then upload to your to your
friends or your customers or without and
they run it and there you go
and and
that's expensive to do but but really
limited in terms of the amount of
compute you need to create it the the
the the investment
in compute you can do it on on virtually
any laptop
um what ai and deep learning is
essentially a new kind of software
development
where
algorithms that we have not been able to
to design ourselves as humans
we
we outsource
to software to write so we create
software
that writes software
uh because for for the kinds of things
we can't do so the image classification
was the classic one that started all of
this
we we couldn't write an algorithm that
could detect the difference
to detect that an image was a dog or a
cat accurately
so so we developed this new kind of
software development
uh where
where instead of us directly coding what
that is
we feed
this software a whole bunch of data and
it produces some software for us a
neural network
that that that could then do that
so in this new form
of software development
a fundamental prerequisite a tool is to
have large amounts of compute
to do that transformation from data
into the algorithm
that
you no longer can just do this on your
laptop
you need a big computer to do
to do interesting things anything that's
that's innovative
uh uh pushy pushing the limits and we
know that we're nowhere near full
artificial general intelligence so by
definition we're always going to be
pushing the limits
on the as big a computer as possible to
be right there on the cutting edge and
so the game has changed now in software
development we recognized this really
early on and that's why jensen
uh immediately started investing in
building computers
super computers for our own engineers
and researchers
uh we have celine because we knew that
that that is a prerequisite you can't
even you're not even in the game if you
don't if you don't have a supercomputer
to to train these models
but um our
our uh hope is to take all the good work
that we're doing here and all these
investments and share it with everyone
so they can build on top of it
um we're not going to hoard it for
ourselves
uh what would you what would you say
like the
the top like objective like what was the
idea behind creating omniverse because i
mean there are already there obviously
was 3d uh
you know environment creation stuff it
like is the i like
like what what what what's the what's
the plan like what's the long-term plan
with omniverse especially when like
right now it seems to me to there's like
so many like
side apps like you have you know omni or
like it's called just called create
right and then you've got like isaacson
for example and like i i feel like i can
do a lot of the same things and create
as i can do in
um isaac sim so like is there a plan to
ever kind of like bring everything
together and then also that's the
question idea behind omniverse
so there's
there's two parts to omniverse like two
sides of the same coin
um
the the first part is about building
virtual worlds
before you can
you can do anything with the virtual
worlds you have to be able to construct
them
so we we we need virtual worlds that are
large
that are representative
of of the fidelity that we find in the
real world
that match
um
uh parameters in the world so that when
we run our simulations on them we can be
we can be certain that our simulations
are producing accurate results we need
the materials and how they look how they
behave in our physics systems to be
correct
and
building these worlds are hard
if you look at
any industries
any areas where people build large
virtual worlds
typically it involves many different
disciplines
teams with many disciplines working
together
using a variety of tools no not one tool
but many different tools that are
specific to their discipline so you
could go go to pixar
and see what their pipelines look like
to make uh toy story
uh for
and
in that pipeline there will be a
thousand plus artists and
and engineers all working together to
construct the virtual world they're
going to render they are using many many
external tools like maya
and houdini
and
tools for painting in photoshop
you you name it virtually everything is
used
but they also have a ton of tools
they've written in-house that are
specific for
how they they do their
um uh development and their their movies
they have their own animation system
like presto
and so
the problem that we've had throughout
the history of computer graphics with
all of these tools is none of them
can work together
uh they
when you export and import into uh from
one tool into another
generally that process is extremely
lossy
uh the representation of of the data of
the virtual world in maya is very
different than it is in blender
uh even though largely they're
describing the same things
pixar solved this
this problem by creating universal scene
description usd
uh what we looked at when we saw that we
looked at it as essentially the html for
for 3d worlds
by by having a common standard and
allowing all of these tools
to contribute
to the same common world building one
source of truth for the
super set of things you might describe
in that world
that opens up a huge opportunity here
we can now combine
um not just
different disciplines within the same
industry
but we can start thinking about bringing
in data from completely different
industries
i might have a robot that um that has a
a description of itself in the virtual
world
that comes from a cad program
you know maybe you designed it in
solidworks or or inventor
and you can take that that description
of the robot that's accurate
uh for manufacturing and put it inside a
building like the one uh we're looking
at right now one of bmw's factories
which was designed in revit
and and stations that were laid out
there for the robots in the factory
using bentley micro station
and and paint um textures and create
materials in adobe substance
and combine all of these things together
so that's
that is the first part of what we really
wanted to do
is is established a common way
to
to describe these virtual worlds so that
we can use all of the existing tools out
there
with with um
leveraging all of the expertise people
who are experts in those tools are to
contribute to the same common world
the that we create so people don't have
to go relearn anything
the other side of the coin
once is once you have these large
virtual worlds
that are high fidelity
you need a way to simulate in them
you want to simulate
the physics of light and matter how
light interacts with the scene so it
tells us what it looks like
that same physics
uh um
that simulation which we call rendering
applies to
wavelengths that aren't visible
so you can use that for wi-fi
for lidar for radar all of these things
that are super important for robots and
autonomous vehicles or for ericsson when
they're laying out their 5g towers we
can use that that same fundamental
simulation technology that we've used
for creating pretty images that
entertain us it's it's actually a
physics simulation that's useful for a
broad range of things
we need to simulate general physics
how do objects interact with each other
in this world what's the behavior
so that we can predict
whether the designs that we are creating
are going to be good designs
when we design a car when we design a
factory that's going to build that car
you want to make sure before you invest
the billions of dollars in building the
factory
and building that car
that it's it's going to be good it's
going to work and it's going to be safe
and and
uh delightful for your customers
um that simulation is
is key
to building the the things that we need
to build nowadays the complexity they're
at there's no way we're going to build
all of the new bridges and skyscrapers
and
and uh levees
and all of the things that we need to to
to build to buttress our environment and
infrastructure without simulating them
first and in order to do that kind of
simulation
um
we need a lot of compute
and we need a framework
a software framework that can scale to
this large amounts of compute
we we look at game engines as amazing um
uh
as
as an amazing it's a testament to what
uh what our industry can do
with world simulation that
we we've developed these amazing engines
that create something that's real world
and life like that we can go play video
games in
um and and we thought
well what if we took this
this game engine world simulator thing
and made it work for
for real world kinds of simulations
so that we can do simulations for our
robots and autonomous vehicles and what
we found was that as great as the game
engines are their primary focus
is is making games which don't have to
be physically accurate
and and they need to run
on as many devices as possible
small computers relatively small
computers like phones and consoles and
and and the like
what we need
is a way to run
arbitrarily complex simulations at the
highest fidelity possible
and
and uh we're okay
having uh multi-million dollar super
computers running those simulations but
we need a software stack a simulation
stack a framework that can scale to
those super computers
and that doesn't exist today uh it
doesn't exist with the game engines or
any other simulation frameworks so so we
built it that and we're continuing to
build it and and extend this
for our um autonomous vehicle simulation
drives him
um
we need
we need a high fidelity world that's
indistinguishable
to the to the computer the brain that we
put inside the car
uh from the real world
we substitute the
the camera sensors the lidar and radar
sensors that we plug into the actual
computer for the car
with output from our simulator from
drive sim
and it has to happen in real time so we
can do hardware in the loop simulation
but that that rendering has to be
indistinguishable to the ai from the
real world which
which means that we need an extremely
powerful computer to run all that many
gpus because there are many sensors
there's a dozen cameras lidars and
radars that are all running at real time
there's kind of like no limit to the
scale at which we can do this so we
built omniverse for that purpose but in
doing all of this our philosophy has
been don't build anything
we're not building anything others have
already done
if somebody else is already doing
something well we just want to connect
it in with there's not there's too many
things to build out there for us to go
build it all we we prefer to connect the
existing things and augment them with
the things other uh others aren't going
to build anytime soon
so something you mentioned was
drive sim and i've seen that referenced
a couple of times and the first time i
saw that i went to go
see if i could find drive sim in
omniverse and i don't see it is that is
that something yeah coming or what's the
deal there so
so in a general sense drive civ and
isaac's sim aren't really different
right um they're both
simula they're robotic simulators right
it just uh
autonomous vehicles are a special kind
of robot
um
in some ways they're much harder the
simulation simulation we need to do for
them and the development is much harder
than general robotics right now and in
some ways it's easier
they're robots that really try hard to
avoid touching other things so we know
that in robotics manipulation is one the
the harder of the problems over
between navigation and manipulation
manipulation is is the harder more
unsolved problem right and so that that
one's avoided and it's largely a 2d
thing so your control is on the 2d plane
uh
essentially so that makes it that makes
it a lot easier
but
um
uh the
since we are closer
to productizing
this that kind of robotics
this and the scale is so large and
there's so much danger in
in unleashing
uh ais onto our roads that are that are
not smart enough
it is imperative it's critical
that we do
as much simulation as possible and as
close to the real world as possible to
ensure that our
our ai's are smart and they're doing the
right things
so we're building that system as we
speak and it's the number one
reason for why we built omniverse
because that's a big market it's an
important market and it's one we can't
uh we can't
uh afford to be wrong at when we we
don't want to put stupid stupid cars out
there we need them to be smart
so when i when i saw drive sim at least
what went through my head is kind of
like what i was asking before is like
what i would hope for
is like like you know all these cars
would either have camera sensors lidar
ultrasonic sensors stuff like that i
can't even remember i think lidar is
maybe not yet
it is
okay um
so like those things and those are again
very difficult to
uh
accurately
model in many sims but again if you've
got uh
ray tracing i would imagine that that
kind of
goes in
uh pretty much perfectly we use ray
tracing for that it's a it's a very
natural for lidar and and radar as well
and and in the keynote jensen talks
about a bit uh we've we've created
material models for
for that uh part of the spectrum for for
lidar
and uh and we're developing one for
radar as well
uh something that's that's not commonly
done or as far as i know
um but my
where i'm getting to with this is that
um drive sim is the number one
application for omniverse
so
so all of the stuff we're developing for
for drive sim
that can be generalized goes into
omniverse
and omniverse is a toolkit you can use
to build the simulators like isaac's sim
anyone can actually take omniverse and
build their own special simulator
and system on top of it it's it's a
platform a development platform for that
eventually i think we may we may put
drive sim out there or license it out we
i don't think we've decided on that but
for right now it's still
it's still like really on the bleeding
edge of development and it requires
very specialized
uh a big iron gear to run
uh the way we're running it uh you need
to to simulate all of those sensors in
real time simultaneously with hardware
in the loop
uh you're talking about a computer with
dozens of gpus
uh and and specialized interconnects
it's a super computer so it's not for
everyone it's not like even if you
downloaded drive sim today you're not
going to be able to run that on your
laptop
so what would be the heavy part then so
like is it just simply
um
is it the set the number of sensors or
do you have i guess in drive 7 you'd
have like pedestrians and cars and all
kinds of other things going on or
yeah first first and foremost the worlds
are large i mean it's it's arbitrarily
large right if uh we want to get to the
point where we can drive across a
continent from los angeles
to new york uninterrupted
and like uh like i said we're really
going for here is essentially virtual
reality for the ai
so we take the computer that would
actually be in the car
that has
uh connectors for the sensor inputs and
we replace those
uh sensor inputs with outputs from the
simulator like video out from the
simulator plugging right into it
so it has to run in real time
but worlds that are
continent scale
and each pixel
has to be faithful to what what the
actual camera would see right
that
that is essentially an endless problem
like to to do
that fidel the fidelity rendering we
want
you know for vfx and and film like stuff
that's indistinguishable from the real
world they spent computer days worth of
of rendering time on the computer per
frame and we're we need to do that in a
60th of a second
and we need to do it for dozens of
sensors
so
so one gpu
uh is nowhere near enough to do all of
those sensors at that fidelity we
we
uh we need a much bigger computer to do
that and so we're building omniverse as
a simulation framework that lets us
scale to that so you can put these large
large-scale worlds in there and crank up
the fidelity and accuracy just by
throwing more compute power at it
eventually our computers get more
powerful our gpus get more powerful so
you can run them on smaller and smaller
computers for a given data size set size
and it'll make more sense uh to get give
others access to that but but all of the
stuff we're doing for sensor simulation
um for the world creation and and all of
the features that are in there are just
in omniverse and they're in isaacson so
you could you could potentially make
something like drive sim on top of
isaac's sim
um say say you wanted to make a delivery
robot to go deliver
to simulate delivery of uh of food
from
from restaurants like
do a doordash kind of thing
that's essentially a drive sim problem
but
um so so we'll see over time we'll we'll
um
we'll be releasing more and more of the
things we're building for dry sim it's
just not ready yet right now for general
consumption i think most most people
couldn't couldn't use it in its current
form well at least
from my perspective what i would want
from drive sim and maybe it doesn't even
need to be called drive sim is the same
thing i
asked about earlier is like
i just want an asset that is i just want
the car and maybe like some roads or
something like that it doesn't have to
be an entire continent uh i just wanted
and that's coming
so as far
as right right as far as the world
building part um
there are besides us there's there are a
lot of companies out there that are that
are building these assets and making
them available companies like turbosquid
shutterstock turbosquid and not so you
should you should look at that see
what's already out there but surely the
problem there is it would not have the
uh like the hard part in my head the
thing that the thing that i'm trying to
skip doing is uh
adding in each individual sensor because
i think that's still
i don't think i could just grab
something from turbosquid and and let's
say the front-facing camera that's not
gonna that's not gonna work i've gotta
still go into
um
you know isaac sim and like add those
things in
correct
yes you're going to have to place the
sensors relative to the car but i don't
think that's that hard right now to do
we've we've added tooling to make that
easier
over time we would like for for these
libraries like turbo squid to have
richer assets for our simulations that
already come pre-configured with all of
that stuff and and and that is
definitely something we are um
uh pursuing i can't i can't talk about
specifics but
but our dream is
for for um
omniverse to open up new markets for all
of these content providers so that
they're incentivized to create
richer assets that have more than just
the geometry
and textures but also have
um
uh all of the physics materials they
have the rigs so the cars are rigged up
you can just drive them
for indoor scenarios you know
it's really important to have
uh to have your assets be rigged for
things like drawers and refrigerators
and cabinets
uh all of the physics and the joints and
stuff generally speaking
none of the content out there
has any of that stuff it's really basic
but we're um
we're we're trying to standardize the
description of all that stuff to make a
uh
to make a market for them to go produce
that and that's usd essentially is what
you're saying yeah so we start with what
usd is today
uh which describes a lot of it but not
all of it there's uh physics and
behavior and these things aren't
standardized in there you can add it you
can add that information but there isn't
a common way to describe it
but we started working with others to to
evolve it in the same way that
evolved greatly from its inception from
html one in 1993
to html5
um 2010 or whenever that was
there was a lot of stuff added in the
early days you couldn't do things like
video or have a rich application with
asynchronous ui events
like gmail or google maps
uh but but all of those things were
added
to to html to give us the experience
that we have today we believe the same
is going to happen with usd and we're
accelerating that so last year we worked
with both pixar and apple
to to add one of the first uh schemas to
to the usd standard to describe rigid
body physics
and that has become part of the standard
now
and we're working on more such things
and we think it's going to be a journey
this is something that's going to just
continue going the same way it has for
html and html hasn't ended it definitely
is going to continue for 3d data and we
believe that's usd
and describing 3d worlds is much more
complex
than describing a 2d web page so by
necessity we need to
uh we we need to create these these new
standards
let's get it together got a comment in
the chat that i think is kind of
interesting and i know it's not
available now but the concept i think is
really interesting you've got you know
you've got stuff like audio to face
which is an application now in omniverse
and obviously that started with just
like a neural network that would that
would produce that for us
and um zartrus in the in the chat said
suggested that you know
is there a possibility in the future
that someone can because i've seen
people do this where you you take a
photo
and then that photo is converted to like
a 3d space and that yeah we've got that
canvas 3d that would be so cool to have
in in something like because that would
be uh because then even then you could
like set up you know your obviously
you'd have to make some slight tweaks
and stuff like that to the physics once
it's loaded in because obviously a photo
doesn't contain physics but you but it
could i mean there's it could be
inferred from the photo so
uh
is there anything well we did that and
that's actually available in omniverse
right now that just take a photo
technology
canvas 3d it's an extension uh that's
available you can enable it if you go to
the extension manager and create
you can enable it and you can give it a
photo of any car
and it will
almost instantly create a 3d car for you
with texture and rigged so you can drive
it around
uh is it only like anything for a car or
it could be
is it is there that one is only for a
car
the the technique is generalizable too
much to everything
but the one we put out there just as an
experimental thing for people to play
with is only for cars
that was developed by um
uh within the omniverse theme we have a
basic research lab in ai
that's dedicated to 3d content creation
um it's led by professor sonja fiddler
from university of toronto where modern
deep learning in ai was kind of born
uh
she's amazing and she's assembled this
amazing team
that is bridging ai and computer
graphics
and simulation
uh so so that that that particular
technology was published and that's from
her group
um
uh uh our team there
which is part of the omniverse theme and
it's it's just a
a little taste of the things that are to
come i mentioned earlier that
um
today building
uh high fidelity large 3d worlds is
really hard there's only a small number
of experts that can do that
and we we believe that in order for us
to build what we need
all of the virtual worlds that everybody
needs to use to build everything else we
need to make that skill
or the those skills available to
everyone and the way we're going to do
that is with ai
ai has to assist in this construction
and so this lab that we have
is is for that purpose we
we know that there's no way we're going
to scale doesn't matter how great our
simulators are how perfect they are if
you can't give them give the simulators
the data the worlds
to simulate you can't make enough of
them then it kind of doesn't matter so
so we see omniverse
um
as solving both problems the simulation
and and the world creation
uh problem there are two sides of the
same coin
uh just again from my own personal notes
so this was an extension in uh the
create app in omniverse and what was the
extension called
i believe it's called ganvers
g-a-n you know like ganvers
yeah uh
uh generative adversarial adversarial
networks so ganvers 3d
very cool cool i'm going to definitely
have to
there's some there's some videos out
there so we have a whole bunch of uh
little tutorial videos and stuff on
omniverse i think if you just search for
it um google or youtube um search for
omniverse ganvers 3d it'll come up and
i'll show you how to use it
cool yeah shout out to the uh the
omniverse team i i uh was it called on
twitch i think i followed them on twitch
and then i see they're like always
they're always putting out content so if
you're interested in this stuff
definitely
they've got a bunch of youtube stuff and
then uh
twitch stuff too that you can come in
and even talk to them live so if you're
interested yeah and we we have a cool
discord
um where where uh much of the omniverse
team
frequents so if you ask questions there
or come come chat there's others in the
community that are
that are really starting to um
gain expertise in it and can help others
out it's a discord dot gg slash nvidia
nvidia omniverse one word
um
so one of the other things too that i
think is
pretty newly announced as of today is
the ar and vr
uh side uh can you tell us a little bit
more about that i saw the ar is like in
beta and then vr is coming i hope yeah i
think that's right yeah it's coming in
beta these are capabil fundamental
capabilities to omniverse kit
that we're making available we've we've
shown them in different forms and and
stuff throughout the years as we've
shown omniverse but uh we feel it's
they're far enough along now that that
we're we're gonna make it available
um
uh to the general public to build on top
of so the a with ar
you can download
a companion app for your ios device
called omniverse remote
that allows you to connect to
to the computer that has the rtx card
running omniverse
and and uh have the rendering of the
virtual part of your
ar scene
uh done by the bigger computer with the
generating the better pixels
streaming it to the ios device which can
then um
composite
the the rendered image into the uh
the the real world camera feed so you
get you get that ar feeling but without
the limitations of the
the rendering capabilities of the device
and is that is that like pretty pretty
quick at inference and stuff like are
you guys finding that you know with a
typical rtx gpu that people are able to
do that or like what kind of gpu yeah
you know
your as long as the content
that that you're
rendering uh
as long as the gpu that you're using is
capable of rendering that content at
real time frame rates then
then yes it's great um
uh
there is no limit to the complexity of
content you can create obviously you can
always create a bigger world that has
more complexity in there so at some
point it stops being real time and that
all just depends on
the computer so
um but if you have
any of our modern uh modern gpus with
rtx then then there's a lot of cool
stuff you can do and it's definitely far
more capable at rendering and rendering
high quality than than what a
five watt you know ipad can do
or or another as amazing as as those
devices are you're you're limited by the
capabilities of of the thing that's
driven by a battery
if you can plug a computer into a wall
you can do a lot more computation
and so this is a way of having the best
of both worlds you can be untethered
uh have your air experience on the
device you want to display on but the
computation is happening on on a bigger
computer
uh that's connected to it and
potentially even in the cloud you can
you can run it it doesn't even have to
be in the same room with you uh you can
run it on aws or google cloud
so just to stop for a second i think
what's on right now is what i referenced
earlier so this is
maxine so my question would be again
getting back to my my dream
uh can can i
is that the only avatar essentially that
we can use or can we
transfer learn our own face into that
uh okay
can you create uh put your own face into
this avatar yes yes that's the
uh that's exactly i think what we were
showing here
we have a whole host of technologies for
creating these avatars ranging from
photorealistic coming from real world to
imaginary
artistic ones um
but yes one of the options is is to use
your own image
and drive your
drive yourself
but that image could be
uh uh with you wearing different clothes
makeup
or dressed a certain way so you can be
untidy and unkempt
ahead
in real life but but seem as if uh as if
you're all dressed up well that's one of
the other things that we've seen
at least over the last
for sure year but probably longer it's
all all kind of a blur now but
the
just like the technology to like even
right now as we're talking like for me
to look at you i'm looking at my screen
but i've got a webcam over here and
wouldn't it be nice if i was
always able to like look at the webcam
but for me personally that's awkward and
like i i like i feel like i'm losing out
on the personal absolutely if i'm not
looking at you but then it's weird for
you because you're looking at someone
who's not looking at you and so so even
like little subtle things like that and
the fact that again we can just do that
in real time
yeah it turns out a huge part of our
brains
are dedicated to that to to to
deciphering and decoding
what other people
mean or intend based on their gaze
based on their facial expressions
uh based on where they position
themselves in the room relative to you
their body language looks like we're
really really attuned to this stuff we
communicate a lot of information
without saying a word
and often the words that we say
can are are are conveying less
information or the wrong information
than what
the rest of our
our our body is saying
so we're really good at that and when
with video conferencing it just the
reason why it's so tiring for all of us
is because it kind of breaks all of this
right now it looks like you're not
you're not paying attention to me
because you're you're looking away
uh from my face but you're probably
actually looking at me your intention is
to signal to me that you are engaged and
paying attention to what i'm saying
but the way my mind is reading it
is is that you're disinterested because
you're looking away right and i have
this cognitive dissonance because i know
consciously that you are paying
attention
but
there's a signal in my brain saying no
he's not and and that that fights those
two things are fighting each other and
it tires us out that's why we're all
sick of doing this video conferencing
stuff uh and want to meet meet in person
but i think it's technology we can
remedy a lot of that even today i think
it's also two-sided though like i said
like i think not only do you feel like
i'm not listening to you but if i
attempt to listen to you i'm staring at
a a a very
boring
unhuman camera
right and it's it's it's uh yeah it's
because because the camera
isn't aligned with my eyes right
uh which is
you you're you're looking at my face and
probably at my eyes
but the camera is is offset from that so
it looks like you're looking away from
my eyes
we can tell when somebody at a far
distance is actually making eye contact
with you yeah it's really it's like even
though theoretically the resolution of
our eyes shouldn't allow that you can
see them from way across the distance in
our room where we know because that
means something it's meaningful when
somebody somebody's trying to connect uh
connect with you and look at your eyes
and communicate something to you
but this completely breaks it so so we
uh jensen talked about
talks about this in the keynote here
um
uh we've talked about it in the previous
one as well about gaze redirection
uh as one of the one of the
uh cool
cool technologies we have as part of the
maxine toolkit that that could be rigged
up into video conferencing or or or
similar kinds of applications
interesting yeah i'm definitely going to
have to check out maxine again because
again that gets very close to
to what i'm after so is so
in the frame that i've paused on here
they're also showing that you can
convert text to speech into
another language so
is riva connected into maxine like how
what's the structure of this
uh
yes maxine leverages
uh many many of our foundational
technologies including riva
that's how i would look at it like riva
is kind of a lower
lower level component that that could be
used with maxine
interesting okay
yeah i definitely i'm definitely gonna
have to look into maxine some more
um
so the other thing the other thing that
we kind of glossed over was we talked
about ar but then i still want to hit on
vr because again like uh that's just a
just so
so interesting to me to be able to
possibly create you know my own
environments and again yeah like i think
i'm a pretty good test case because i i
don't i don't really like i think i've
used blender maybe once in my lifetime i
don't use photoshop i'm not good at any
of these things but again like in with
omniverse i'm able to kind of create
what i need to create
uh pretty quick and then so the concept
of possibly being able to continue using
omniverse to create
something in vr and then be able to pass
through
robots that i've also created and have
those in vr interacting with me in vr
like that's
that's really staggering so so like what
what's the road map there do i have a
good idea for like is that going to be
possible yeah
i don't know if you remember years ago
we had
uh a project that we we've shown in many
of jensen's keynotes called project
holodeck
um maybe but i've just you can search it
up nvidia holodeck we had built
we had we took a bunch of our rendering
technologies and physics technologies
um actually even before that
um we had another
project we made a mini game physics game
in vr i think it was 2016. yeah 2016
called vr fun house
we took unreal engine and and we added
to it
a bunch of technologies
for rendering in vr
and um
and some cool rendering stuff plus
physics
and and made a
made a
vr experience where you can interact
with the world
using uh a lot of physics stuff which is
super fun we had fire and
and uh uh destruction and
and uh
we had furry
uh bobblehead things on springs and
stuff you should check it out
but we extended that we thought that was
an experiment we had done to see because
it was in the early days of vr
we had a intuition that in vr
um
accurate physics
would probably be
uh really engaging if you if you're for
you to feel immersed inside a world you
need things to to behave correctly and
vr fun house proved to us that that's
true
that that it is it was it was pretty
awesome so we then took it and said well
let's make it multiplayer so many people
can be in the same world together and do
things with physics and we thought well
how about instead of it being a game we
designers could use this so that they
could go look at the things that they're
building like cars and
and products
uh but interact with them physically
with multiple people that could be
different parts of the world
feeling like they're in the same place
so we started project holodeck
and we built this cool cool thing on on
um
on top of unreal engine but soon after
we built that
um we we realized we had the
the runtime part like we could do all
the interaction but the real problem
was getting all of the content into
these worlds to build them
and importing from everywhere else
and that really
uh brought it home that we needed to
build
what is now omniverse first
before we can tackle that problem like
the actual world construction problem is
is uh a major
uh the major part of that so we took a
break on project holodeck um
and went off to go build omniverse but
the intention has always been that we'll
get back to
to to using all of this stuff for vr ar
and
and all of the new modes of immersive
experiences
we've had vr
technically working in omniverse for a
long time
but
but it's not enough to just make the
the the stuff render in stereo and and
experience in there you need a whole ux
a user experience so you can navigate
around the vr world so you can
manipulate objects in there
we need a toolkit that lets you create
uis inside the vr world and all that and
so we that wasn't the highest priority
at the earlier parts of omniverse we
just needed to get everything working we
need to get rendering and physics and
and and and the basics uh up and running
uh but now that we're a little bit
further along we're enabling um these
these things that have been the plan all
along our goal is
is to get to the point where
uh
people have have a choice
on how they're going to interact with
these 3d worlds and content if you
want to experience it with mouse and
keyboard looking at it through your
monitor as a window into it that's fine
if you want to see it
um you want to mix it with your other
reality with our reality using ar
glasses or or your
or an ipad or something like that and
place that virtual world on a tabletop
and and experience it that way go right
ahead if you want to
be inside the virtual world and feel
like you're you're in there immersed in
it then vr is the way to do that and and
um with omniverse nucleus
we we can
connect many people
into the same world and all of them can
have
different views into it in different
modes
so it's not either or you can be one
person can be inside in vr and another
could be viewing them that person on the
in the virtual world on a tabletop
through their ipad while a third person
is connected to it with blender
or or maya and
and modeling and changing the world on
the fly like their god in inside this
virtual world
um
we have all the foundational
technologies to enable that today and
what you're seeing here is us
is opening up um some of the technology
that's been in there for a while because
it's becoming robust enough
uh and uh polished enough so that so
that we feel
uh
uh okay unleashing it into the developer
community so they can develop new
experiences
what i want is commitment i want an eta
when when can i
play with that
uh the vr very very soon like it's it's
working so it's good
i i don't want to
the way the way i feel is that
there's nobody on the omniverse team
that is sitting around idle and lazy
they're they're all working really hard
and so
this is a priority for them they're
going to release it as soon as it's
ready
because they want it in in your hands
but if i force them to release it
earlier than they think it's ready then
you're going to have a bad experience
but uh so i don't like to put a specific
date but it's on the order of weeks uh
at the most uh we we announced it it's
out there i think i think actually you
can enable vr right now there's there's
a whole bunch of stuff there's like
hidden easter not not even easter eggs
they're just in the extension manager
and in the render settings and stuff i
think you can if you go to the render
settings you can enable vr mode
the stuff that that's coming is a lot of
the things i mentioned like navigation
and
locomotion inside
inside the vr world and manipulation and
all the ux kind of features
so
uh is that like vr
is that in
um
create or is that also in like things
like isaac sim and stuff like that
so it's in kits
which is the framework all of these
applications are built on so
theoretically it's in all of them
but i want to go to like uh
i don't know some file menu and say you
know
send to x display and that display
happens to be
um some vr headset
is is that kind of
what's coming or like how what would be
like the pipeline like i've got my
environment i've got my robot in there
and i want to interact physically with
my robot um what would i what what is
your hope for how i would do that
there's there's two ways i would imagine
you can do it
at home
you can either the same machine you're
running isaac sim on
um you can just flip it into vr mode and
your vr
hmd is connected to that computer
so
on the screen you'll see the two views
the stereo views and you just put on the
the
the um
hmd and and go do your thing in there
and when you're done you take it off and
you get out of vr mode and it goes back
into desktop mode the other way you can
do it is by hosting that virtual world
on a nuclear nucleus server
local
inside your network so it might be the
same workstation
and if you have another machine that
you're using for vr
that's different from this one
that you can load that same scene up
from nucleus on that other machine and
even another app like create
uh while isaac sim is running
uh
on the same usd data in the same virtual
world
and and you can put on that headset and
use that separate computer for vr while
this
uh the first computer can be used for
editing or running the simulation in
isaac sim
the the problem you have in running it
all on one computer is that you become
limited to the total compute
capabilities of that one machine
vr is not cheap it's you need high
resolution and you need stereo
so so you need a fairly powerful
computer and and a lot of gpu horsepower
which doesn't leave much budget for you
to run your physics simulations or
other things you might want so it all
kind of depends on
on the scale of the simulation and the
way you're trying to use it
um we're we're giving you the
capabilities and the flexibility to
to do this whatever way works best given
your your configuration
uh one thing but uh after this but
speaking of high power gpus i just want
to
mention that if you sign up for gtc
there is a link in the description
uh it is free to sign up there's lots of
really really interesting talks
including on like omniverse stuff like
that
you have a chance to win one of two 30
90s
so
sign up if you haven't uh it's
definitely one of the best gpus you
could possibly have for stuff like this
so it's what i'm using i love my 30 90.
um so uh yeah you mentioned so you could
have like a
a computer on network
uh is there a reason why we couldn't
just have like a public ip and then do
it that way too or is this like a
security risk like absolutely
yeah so um
um
if you're gonna put it uh put a public
ip put it out there then you need to
ensure it's secured so you can vpn or
encrypt it some somehow
um over time we're
we hope to make that easier to do
so
so i ideally
at some point in the future
uh you don't even have to buy a computer
to use omniverse
you can just rent them as you need we
obviously do that already for video
games we have geforce now
um
uh so you don't you don't have to buy pc
to play
uh uh these games with full rtx quality
at 3080 level you can just
subscribe to one there
and um
uh i can't give any any specifics or
dates but but obviously that that that's
that's the future right well obviously
in theory you could spin up like an aws
server or something like that and you
could do it yourself on there and then
just connect to it that way it's just
like you you're renting a pc in the
cloud and you can do whatever you want
with it and and there are pcs in the
cloud that are omniverse compatible or
capable so
yeah that's crazy i
i all i know is like i can't see past
that horizon you know of like what what
happens then you know i just know that
sounds this is so cool like the concept
of it
and it's kind of like with like
transformers today you know we're just
kind of starting to see some cool stuff
like i've been playing with
the co-pilot
and uh
i think these are things that are just
going to completely
just just paradigm shift of the way that
we view so many things i don't know if
it'll always be co-pilot it'll be
probably many iterations later
but in the same thing here i agree with
you i think there's going to be all
kinds of emergent
things
amazing things that happened that we
couldn't quite predict
um
i i've always found it odd
that
um
for essentially
all applications that aren't 3d
they've all moved into the cloud
primarily
but 3d applications are primarily run at
the edge on your device
and if you would think it would be the
inverse because like
3d world simulation and the data sets
associated with 3d it's so big yeah that
it makes more sense for that to be
concentrated in the cloud with data
gravity
now the reason why that hasn't happened
is because 3d is just super super hard
and you have this fragmented ecosystem
of all these different tools that all
speak different languages and all of
that so we wanted
to build omniverse
to allow that
if we can describe the world in a common
way and make a framework so that many
different um compute entities can
connect into that same world and operate
on it then we essentially cloud enable
it
if you think about the applications you
run today one of the most common ones
like a google search
that is that is an application that's
impossible for you to run
at the edge
you could not do a google search
completely on your phone
or on your pc that requires access to
enormous amounts of data that can only
fit in a large data center somewhere and
every time you type in a few words into
the
to the text entry box and press enter
get that instantaneous response you've
touched terabytes and terabytes of data
probably dozens or hundreds of computers
did something with all these little
microservices and stuff
operating there but to you it looks like
it's just
one application running in your web
browser you know right right very simple
3d
if we do this right will become like
that where
where the stuff
that we do inside these 3d worlds has
has
an enormous amount of like un
unimaginable amount of computing with
algorithmic innovations and stuff
happening
but all instantaneous behind the scenes
without you even knowing
and they're they're we're going to do
things that are only possible because
it's in the cloud
you would not be able to do that
computation
in that period of time or at all
on on the device you're actually
experiencing it on so this is the first
steps towards doing that we need to
we need to construct the plumbing we
need to describe the standard standard
ways of describing the data and then we
need the plumbing to connect all of
these systems together with
microservices databases and all that
stuff so we can enable these new kinds
of applications that are
just right now unimaginable we don't
know what they're going to be like in
the same way we couldn't have imagined
all of the web applications we have
and all the apps that we have back in
1993 when the web first arrived
well i think yeah it's it's not even
just just can't imagine too it's like um
you know like when i was first poking
into
uh gptj which you can theoretically run
run locally pretty quickly and even that
is accessing a theoretic theoretical
like knowledge base of
i can't remember how big it is now but
but a very large uh corpus of just
knowledge
um and i think a lot of people are you
know
they see that and they're like well what
do we really what do we do with this you
know and it's like well it's just it's
not a general intelligence but it's
generally intelligent
and even though today maybe most people
can't run something like gpdj or any of
these other let's say five to 10 billion
parameter models maybe not yet on your
phone but in a few years you will be
able to or you could run it on some sort
of raspberry pi size device um
what but then there's going to be a
a model that's thousands of times bigger
than that that can only run in the cloud
right so there's going to be all these
new changes that yeah exactly you'll
have
much much larger models that are again
going to be
uh generally intelligent
and it's just trying to like start it
again it's like it's like
i see that that's the horizon i don't
know what's beyond that but i do know
these are technologies and capabilities
that we've we've really never
had before like like you mentioned like
google search that's kind of the first
the first one that i can think of that
is like gives a someone immediate access
to the world of knowledge
but something
you know beyond that with these very
very large transformer models
um
it's not just google like you because
most people can't just connect into
google search api i mean they do have
like an api but it's very you got you
get rate limited very quickly so so you
could not have
a robot with this sort of general
intelligence unless you were you know
amazon or google or one of these other
very large tech companies whereas
nowadays no you you can download that
model and you can order right now or you
can get it from us right so what i mean
is like now you can like yeah getting
back to like riva and stuff like that is
yeah you can you can grab these models
and they're already optimized like that
was i think for me personally the the
biggest surprise
was
the the captioning
the transcription rather where um just
how fast it it it worked and then from
there at least what i did was i used the
um
the the asr and then fed that through uh
it was a dilo gpt from i grabbed that
model from hugging face i did not train
that model and so pass it through that
model get the get the inference response
basically a chatbot response and then i
used uh text-to-speech again from riva
to respond to me and again that whole
process i fed that through the
microphone and then it talked back to me
over the speakers and it was very
uh very fluid and i think that whole
project took me
i don't know 40 40 minutes maybe to
complete and like do on a tutorial
whereas uh you know to do all of those
steps myself
would have taken
i don't even know how long and i don't
think i could have gotten the inference
to be that quick even though again that
was all running on my own hardware
so we have a large large team of people
whose only job it is to make
that inference quick
and they're the world's experts on
computer science and computer
architectures like there's there's just
no way you could do that i know i can't
i can't do that
we have the world's best people
for those specific things doing that and
and we can
we can justify dedicating them to this
because it's going to be used
by many more than just us
we do this because you can go leverage
it and so can thousands or maybe
millions of others
um
that's that's fundamentally our position
in this we are
we are uh
tools makers where
we're
we create core technology that others
can use as building blocks
to build their applications
we're not we're not looking to go
make the end applications the final
solutions
even though i mean you guys are very
close to to doing just that i mean it's
it's like yeah they're just like these
end piece
um
software bits that yeah someone like me
can just kind of you know just plug in
real quick and it's like boom i have a
very nice chat bot
that is like something that i could not
have created and i would not and you can
go specialize that to your problem right
for exactly we're not going to be we
we're
there's a lot of people at nvidia but by
the grand scheme of things it's not that
many we're about 20 000 people in in
this company it's actually much smaller
than if you look at other equivalently
sized companies there there's only so
many things we can do
but there's only so many hours of the
day that our engineers can type
we can't go make every application that
every person
needs in the world so we go focus on the
core common
things that are super hard to do that
we're particularly good at doing that
that we can add value with
and then we provide that to others so
that they can go specialize that and and
and apply it to their uh to their
problem domain
and that's what omniverse is as well you
had asked earlier about you know you see
that there's overlap with some existing
tools that's not at all what we're
trying to do we want to use all those
existing tools but augment them with
unique capabilities that only we
we can really provide given our special
capabilities and our experience and our
our
uh
our passion
so i just happened to catch someone in
chat suggesting um
asking about like basically gaming gpus
versus doing stuff like deep learning um
what do you think the the focus is of
nvidia primarily is it is it gaming or
is it um
uh what would you call it gp gpu use i
suppose like gpu accelerated is it just
everything gpu accelerated or like kind
of what what's the thinking
so
how to answer that exactly we haven't
been
only a gaming company or only anything
company for a long long time
we started with gaming from the very
beginning
because
we knew that in order to build the uh
are you getting an echo by the way no
i'm okay
possibly if someone says in chat but
multiple people would have to say in
chat people lie
i see okay i'm getting an echo but i
don't know
but uh i'm not sure where that's coming
from i'll try to speak um
ignoring my own voice
um so we started we started our history
our life at nvidia
1993 uh to building a accelerator
or rendering
so we could do real-time rendering and
the first
market
jensen identified for it was one that
didn't exist yet but he believed was
going to be important is video games 3d
video games
we love video games all of us are gamers
around here i'm a gamer by myself
but
the reason we chose that one was because
we understood that it was going to be
big enough
to fuel the r d we need to do to build
the accelerated computing stack
that that we want to build to expand
into other things
because the fundamental technology and
algorithms
and um
and innovations that we create for video
games are useful for a much broader set
of things
to this day
video games is a huge part it's still
about half of our revenue
but increasingly it's becoming a smaller
share because we've expanded into
into general compute high performance
computing
pro visualization and most recently for
almost 10 years now deep learning
and and all of that is growing into the
data center so our
our businesses
and where our revenue comes from share
wise it's starting to shift
uh
gaming will always be a big part of it
but we're doing other things autonomous
vehicles robotics and all that
but fundamentally
what we're doing is the same
we're building a computing stack to
accelerate computing for simulation or
really hard problems
uh for
um
not all problems we're we're not
uh
we haven't been like uh
general
general computing companies general chip
companies that only build cpus
where you can run any program
we've gone and focused on in areas
where
speed and large amounts of data and
compute really really matter
and we've created
full computing stacks
that include not just our chips but the
system software
compilers libraries and sdks
solutions and even applications
to
to accelerate that and make meaningful
differences there gaming was the first
one of those and we'll continue doing
that but we're
we're expanding into everything else and
i think you're seeing
um you're seeing that every day with all
the things we show out there and
definitely in this keynote
um also
it's no secret that we make more than
gpus we
we gpu is the primary thing that we do
and what we excel at and um nobody as
far as i'm concerned comes close
to to making the gpu as great as ours
but we also have made cpus they've been
in our
tegra devices in our uh edge edge vice
forever arm-based cpus
and uh
earlier this year at last gtc we
announced grace
which is our big data center super
supercomputing class
cpu that's coming later we have built on
arm
and we we also have a dpu our data
data center processing unit data
processing unit
which
uh is an extension of all of the
technology
we acquired when we acquired melanox
we're looking at data centers as the new
unit of computing
when we think of a computer it's no
longer
just this pc that's sitting next to your
desk
or your phone or a console
the whole data center we think of as one
computer and that means all of the
processors
and the networking internet all of that
is part of one architecture so we we
build all of those things
yeah i don't know how much you can speak
to this i haven't kept fully up to date
on it what is the status if you can say
on
the nvidia and amd
um
merger i guess
nvidia amd merger i'm sorry not amd i'm
sorry arm
yeah
so i honestly i don't know any more than
you do whatever's out in the public out
there um
we
we um
we we would like to acquire arm they
would like to be acquired by us
and
and we
we put that out there
and the regulators and
and all of the different countries have
to weigh in these things take time
and um we hope it happens
uh if it doesn't happen it's not the end
of the world either we're building
arm-based cpus as we speak um and we'll
continue to do so
uh we think arm is our arm is really
great but
uh if they were
if the
merger the acquisition does just go
through
i think it's going to be a real boost to
the arm ecosystem we can put the full
might and energy
and power of nvidia's r d
into into armed cpus uh and and and
scale them up and put them in places
they've never been
so i got another question to we'll
probably wrap this up at some point i
don't know how much more time you have
but we're a little over
two hours now but i
since we're talking about cpus and other
compute devices
the other thing that was brought up in
the uh the keynote and i've heard it
before too is uh i think it's cool
quantum and obviously this is for
quantum simulations run on the gpu so it
got me curious whenever that first was
released my my the thing i'm waiting for
is cuda with a q
and that's hopefully it's on some sort
of quantum device that you know nvidia
has developed so
i'm actually in the process of
trademarking that and that's my that's
my exit strategy for youtube
um so what do you guys have like a
future um
plan or obviously maybe not even
something set in stone but is that is
quantum something nvidia's looking into
to possibly we're heavily investing in
it we're we're helping all of
so it's no secret that it's probably
gonna be a little while till we have
um quantum computing be be a common
thing that we're doing we're not not
there yet
but to get there
we need a lot of tools and traditional
computers
to to help us build those quantum
computers to do the simulations to do
the basic science and research for that
and so that's that's how we're playing
that right now that's our contribution
we're investing heavily in that and and
jensen
um in his keynote uh goes goes into
quite a bit of depth on on what our
efforts there are i encourage everyone
to take take a look at that um
once you have a quantum computer you're
not done you need to verify that it's
correct
are you aware if uh quantum um
throws in like that noise and stuff like
that yeah that was like one of the other
interesting things that you know you
can't like the quantum computer might
process quicker but generally you have
to like send mult you have to like
process it multiple times just to make
sure there was like no noise right
right does the simulator simulate that
like the noise or is it a perfect
simulation i believe so i'm not i'm not
an expert on quantum computing uh but
but yes my understanding is that
uh even even once you have a quantum
computer you still need a whole bunch of
traditional compute around it yeah to to
to make it work and so we are
uh
investing heavily in building all of
that infrastructure to enable quantum
computing
and then i think probably the last thing
in my notes that i really wanted to
bring up was coo numeric as well so i
guess that is probably powering rapids i
remember looking into rapids some time
ago
um
i haven't really kept up to date with
that um so i think in the keynote jensen
also
uh said that there's like a numpy
version
that runs on [ __ ] numeric yeah i think
you change one line basically i think
you change import numpy to this and it
automatically accelerates your numpy
code uh which is pretty amazing
yeah yeah i'm super excited to kind of
peek and peek into that and then um
especially for uh like we so last year
uh daniel kukewein myself wrote a book
called neural networks from scratch and
we end up using
um numpy um
and the idea would be to get that on the
gpu so when i see that your your own
stochastic gradient descent and all that
just right in numpy yep yeah yeah and so
but obviously this is all running on the
cpu the idea of this isn't to create our
own framework it's in just to like teach
people how to
um like how this actually works and yeah
and computer graphics um
generally the equivalent of that is
writing your own basic
sphere ray tracer
yeah yeah exactly and so um i i for sure
i i at least can personally attest as we
went through that
um like i learned so much and it's it's
helped me a lot and but anyway like
getting that on to the gpu because going
from here it'd be it'd be cool because
that's i'd love to find out how it works
for you that would be awesome just
that's just like coded yeah yeah exactly
and like that's just a dense neural
network but we would like to
go to do things like reinforcement
learning and trans or
transformers stuff like that and you
know especially when you get to
reinforcement learn
at least some of the reinforcement
learning algorithms and then for sure
transformer models we would like to have
it at that you know raw numpy level
but also the speed of of cuda on the gpu
would be nice for like training the
models and validating that they work so
just seeing that got me excited because
we love the idea
of of bringing gpu acceleration the full
power of our gpus
to
to the bigger world of python
programmers
the the number of people that can code
at cuda the level at the system's level
yeah do it is it's just really hard and
even if you know how to do that
you don't necessarily want to it's
just a lot of work it's hard
but me personally i'd i like to be able
to describe my algorithms at a high
level in python
and and and just have it be fast maybe
it won't be
the maximum possible acceleration
but even if it gets me
less than that if i get a 10x speed up
without having to do anything
and i could just code up this thing and
experiment really quickly that's
extremely valuable because i wouldn't
have in many cases gone through the
trouble of doing the most optimized code
to do some experiment in
in uh in in cuda or c plus right um so
so i i think that's great and in within
omniverse
uh we had a huge debate on
on um
what we should settle on as the primary
scripting or
primary language beginning and of course
as you can imagine
everybody has their favorite language
yeah and and there's always somebody who
wants to create a brand new one
and finally we just converge towards
python because like that's becoming
the lingua franca for all all
all things it turns out that you know
python was adopted earlier on in
computer graphics
in visual effects so that's already
common there the usd
um
the usd library had python bindings and
that's like the most natural way to use
it to begin with
and and then data science and machine
learning and ai that's that's all all
python
so so we're
um
everything inside omniverse is
essentially python but you can drop down
to c plus plus cuda if you need
and and we're even introducing ways of
programming the gpu directly through
python
make it easy for people who are domain
experts in in their physics or the types
of simulation they want to do to
describe
algorithms easily but get the
get as much of the power of the computer
they're running on as possible and keep
that code maintainable as well yeah and
portable
yeah that's so cool they're man
these these like these keynotes and just
the amount of stuff that is like coming
out i mean it's not just from nvidia but
it does it's like i can barely keep up
with what nvidia is doing it's like
there's just so much
just advancements just like you said by
the time you're done training a model
it's like that's it's not even the uh
the industry standard anymore it's
changed
it's just so it's so crazy how quick how
quick things are changing um it's very
exciting
yeah i think i think that's pretty much
everything that i wanted to cover if
there if there's something you think
i've i've missed and i think we went
quite a bit here yeah
this is really great um it's the first
time i've done this and yeah i really
enjoyed it thank you so much for for
giving me the opportunity to
to speak with you and to your audience
yeah sure well thanks for coming on um i
pretty much never live stream so uh it's
definitely not not with somebody else
and stuff so i really appreciate your
time too it's good to have somebody
who's
uh
just so so deeply embedded with with
nvidia that we can ask these questions
basically to the source you know so um
that was definitely super super helpful
it's my pleasure look forward to doing
this again sometime
all right well thanks thanks again
take care all right bye-bye bye-bye
all right guys i'll probably hang out in
the chat for possibly a little longer if
there's any other questions or anything
like that otherwise i'm going to go and
eat breakfast i think
oh i say we have edmar edmar's also with
uh omniverse
where are the free gpus ram and the gpu
so you can
there's a link in the description you
can click that make sure you sign up for
uh gtc and then um searching for the
description here but anyway in the live
stream uh you can click on that link and
sign up and there's a basically out of
the however many people sign up there's
two gpus that will be given away
what's for breakfast i don't know
probably some eggs turkey bacon and
cheese that's typically my go-to
zenny yeah the deep learning book is
finished you can get it at nnfs.io
uh zebo yeah i i probably will
especially
uh i think if i can figure out how to
use it you know a lot of these new
things can be kind of difficult to just
like ramp up very quickly on
so like coup numeric my use case there
would be to
attempt to apply that to
the
nnfs package
so getting that to run on on the gpu
would be
just really really cool so if i can
figure that out yeah i definitely would
do some videos on [ __ ] numeric
uh krishna yeah there is a discord it's
quite literally discord dot gg slash
sentex
uh mental my primary operating system is
ubuntu um
but i also sometimes get in go into
windows i used to be on windows
completely but um maybe like two ish
years ago i switched
uh to ubuntu
shall we have more streams uh possibly i
i think at least for me uh doing streams
um
i don't know i liked this one having
someone else on the stream i i think if
i do more streams i would probably want
i want somebody else like in the stream
so
um like i liked this format generally i
it's very boring to me because usually
like if i'm coding or doing something
i'm like listening to music or or if i'm
doing like a tutorial it's like maybe 15
minutes whereas streams tend to be
hours long and it's very like i don't
know it's it's weird it's weird feeling
to me at least
and like
music on streams is always a
danger
uh did they release kunumeric i as far
as i can tell like that's that's out and
ready to be used right now i think
numeric
is what powers um
uh rapids i'd have to you only see alpha
yeah i mean can you i don't know if you
can download the alpha or not but
um
i assume it would be out
i don't know where i'm seeing worldwide
sanjay's responding to somebody but if
that's about the gpu yeah you can
everyone is eligible for that gpu i've
asked so they'll
they pay for shipping and like the taxes
all that stuff will be paid for so
i think that's all the questions um so i
think i'm going to sign off with this
stream thanks to everybody for watching
again the link is in the description if
you want to sign up to uh gtc
um and be entered i i don't know what
the numbers are now but it was in the it
was like in the hundreds that it's like
two out of something hundred
uh for a chance for it for to win the
gpu so it's pretty good odds and it's
completely free to sign up and there's
there's just endless awesome talks so
definitely definitely check those out
thanks for watching everybody